in a six-month investigation only on CBS
this morning we looked into the way
sexual assault cases are handled by the
United States Air Force Academy we spoke
to more than a dozen current and former
cadets
some of them shared their stories
yesterday in part one of our series I
was sexually assaulted my freshman year
and the sexual harassment eventually
made me leave I was terrified of
reporting because I've heard of things
that happened to people and it did
happen to me so it's not horror stories
do you regret reporting the assault
every day now in the second part of our
investigation the Academy's former top
official on sexual assault reveals
troubling information about the way she
says cases are handled and the Academy
is now responding to our reporting is
the Air Force Academy supportive of
those who report sexual assault I would
have to say absolutely not no Teresa
Beasley worked with sexual assault
survivors for three decades ten of those
years as the United States Air Force
Academy's top official on sexual assault
prevention and response I think deep
down they really don't believe that
sexual assaults are happening I think
they're minimizing the severity of them
do you believe there are some commanders
at the Air Force Academy who believe
that cadets are making up sexual assault
charges absolutely they would say it in
words such as I find it interesting the
timing of this report or I am just
wondering why this cadet hasn't come
forward sooner with this assault Beasley
also told us she believes the Academy
has covered up the circumstances
surrounding two violent attacks on
female cadets that occurred in December
2014 and January 2015 on the public
running and biking trail behind the
Academy the details of which have not
been reported until now CBS News has
learned that two attacks on Falcon trail
behind the Air Force Academy occurred
yes were these attacks sexual assaults
yes both were here
in the head hard enough to each receive
a concussion both were hit from behind
somehow they couldn't see anyone coming
sources tell CBS News both cadets were
administered rape kits at local
hospitals but Beasley says both cases
were prematurely closed by the Air
Force's Office of Special Investigations
agents or OSI what happened they meaning
OSI told me that they didn't believe her
that they think it was a date that went
wrong and I said how did how did she how
did she get hit in the head and they
said well she'll have to tell you that
and somehow her it just they they never
investigated it about a month later we
had a second incident she wasn't
believed either they said she was making
it up and when I asked why they said
that this was always side they said
because her timelines don't match more
than a dozen current and former cadets
told CBS News they've experienced
retaliation by their peers and their
military leadership for reporting sexual
assaults to the Academy that's why some
victims are afraid to sign this form
it's called a 29:10 which the Academy
uses to document assaults CBS News has
obtained Defense Department memos that
confirm at least 16 cases were deleted
for academic year 2014 to 2015 for not
having assigned 29:10 Teresa Beasley
believes those cases should have been
counted by the Air Force Academy which
she says would have resulted in a record
number of cases that year they were
actual reports these were victims that
had come in and told her story and had
received help had assigned victim
advocates had been referred for medical
counseling they were actual victims but
they did not want to sign a 29:10
because they were afraid someone would
find out do you believe they removed
those cases for a reason other than they
didn't have that specific form signed
yes and what was that reason I believe
they wanted to get that number down
because it was the highest we'd ever had
I was reprimanded and they were trying
to they tried to fire me for what they
said was intentionally over inflating
the numbers do you believe you were
retaliated against I absolutely was I
Beasley retired amid threats that the
Academy intended to fire her two weeks
ago the Academy released a scathing 560
page report of investigation into the
office Beasley led and accused her of
quote failing to effectively manage
staff spreading rumors and that our
offices lack of competency jeopardized
victim care but Beasley as well as some
former colleagues and cadets who spoke
with CBS News believe the Academy has
scapegoated her for standing up to
leadership on behalf of sexual assault
survivors you have to stand up to people
who who mistreat others and who oppress
others and I did that and they didn't
like it now this superintendent in
charge of the Academy at the time of
these allegations was Lieutenant General
Michelle Johnson she provided us this
following statement she says quote when
members in the sexual assault prevention
and response office demonstrated they
were not up to that task we immediately
initiated an investigation took actions
appropriate to the findings and worked
tirelessly to ensure victims received
the care they deserved
now as for those rapes we reported that
were on that trail Johnson says that the
US Air Force Academy and law enforcement
investigated both those trail
allegations exhaustively for several
months